yeah welcome to this video playing white
against crap re off Calipari off from
Iceland at least that the flag and let's
transpose to the Sicilian so maybe
tomorrow off variation yep yeah there
are lots of flights against that let's
go for this English a text set up in
fact as I played the sir just two days
before cards lost what this again
Stephen Chokin the candidates so I can
use my very very little knowledge that
night d to e to as the usual way to play
to at least no one move here okay 97
he's attacking de five know I probably
two at once
yeah to be honest I don't really
understand what what is so great about
white set up here laughs he's always got
night before coming maybe I've got Queen
D for no Queen DeForest got 96
mmm nitey form yeah let's um a bit a bit
annoying of course I can just play Queen
d3 yeah okay let's let's do this I
probably need to play this move anyway
at some point all night before I just go
Queen d3 check okay
an end game or queenless middle game
let's put it that way I've got the two
bishops but I've got a bad structure I
hope that this Bishop is so well placed
I can always take this and play opposite
colored bishops but it's not not very
inspiring okay maybe see for trying to
open up the position a bit get rid of
one of the week pawns yes I actually
thought I could maybe take on defiant
but this seems a bit too bit too much
it takes e4 Bishop b4 I've got very good
bishops this is something in fact quite
dangerous for black if he takes with the
night our capture and playroom d 6 it's
a it's a bit tricky he's got this King
on the 8th is a bit of a problem wow
really all you are you going to play out
this one this makes some sense if you've
go rock d 585 Bishop d5 look a seven
bishops e6 circuits not not working okay
so then let's go with this and hope I
can get some play against the King
taking b6 now
I go look the one he might play before
too long
before
yeah maybe prepare that
oh I didn't think about that at all that
is a half that he's actually able to
guess on now okay let's just continue
I'd still I still would assume that I
can do something here check with them
the King here close to the pawns it's
not like I'm usually better or something
but I can maybe profit from my better
really give me give me a passed pawn it
safely located but I don't think I would
have done that cannot take it cannot
take it any way 26
don't care so much about the porn i want
one to activate my pieces here so
graceful
he's very passive
so I want to get get the C porn happen
it takes Roxy for that c8 hanging this
means I'll get both pawns and so I'm
stay active
check
yeah you cannot move myself are now the
sea porn is rolling check
time morning
ah the goddamned timer I really hated
can't believe he got out of this
nonsense wrong yeah I'm okay I could
this is a fab really useless how on
earth did I let him escape here check
you simply shouldn't get any any kind of
activity yeah ASC five is better
yeah c5 was better probably so I think I
didn't play this too badly i mean this
looked really nice putting pressure on
black but I let it just tape here c6 of
course but this is the kind of move you
play when you don't have much time on
the clock Bishop a five wins immediately
can look at this briefly here and this
threatened c6 he cannot prevent it if
you move the bishop I simply the I can
also go see six he cannot he can never
take because of route 36 he's got no
check over yeah well he was so here to
offer a drawing this is the kind of
position value with a single st. second
increment you you will never lose as
white or is black for that matter at the
end yeah thanks for watching